speaking about you charlie man you've
been inspired you like you're not your
typical well actually you were an
average joe who are you you know say as
a dreamer um
and i just always believe that like
everything is possible like not anything
but
um i used to manage two chains for ten
years i discovered two chains when he
was titty boy was a titty boy titty boy
that was his rapper name before he was
two champs
like in the country of georgia
[Laughter]
i used to manage artists um recording
artists from atlanta i had one of the
biggest hip-hop firms um
and
at the height of my career
i was diagnosed with a brain tumor and i
was 300 pounds
and like
facing death i was just like
okay well
you start really thinking about your
dreams when you're about to die the
dreams you didn't accomplish because
because all i knew was
i knew how to make money
but i settled because when i was little
all i wanted to do was be an athlete
like that was my dream like i would
literally
have nightmares where i would die in the
in my
in my sleep and my thought when i would
wake up is like
dang i didn't get to experience what it
was like to have my dream come true
because i buried that athletic dream
because i was always overweight my whole
life
so i said all right i'm gonna be a
businessman and you know my business
took off as a young man i was soldier
boys cameraman
managed you know these recording artists
but then i was like you know what i want
to go back i want to go back to my
original dream
and and that's when i got really
connected with god
and i needed a miracle
and within a year and a half of me
retiring from my business
i
i ran
five marathons i did an ironman
i
i reversed my brain tumor
and
the biggest nike commercial of all time
was dedicated to me to colin kaepernick
commercial i was in it
nike named it after me it was called
dream crazy i made a fan made nike
commercial that inspired nike to create
that film
and it was all about dreams
so all my dreams came true
and that's what made me at that point
say
i want to dedicate my life to making
other people's dreams come true because
i got everything have charlie ever used
any um medicine
like um plant medicine or animal
medicine like how i reverse my brain
tumor was literally just with plants
like i went about them i went vegan
really like the the foundation of
of me solving my issue with food
addiction and just like
my my brain tumor and all that was i
just asked myself a simple question
i said
if you are what you eat
is what i'm eating dead or alive
and i just started looking at food as if
like all right if i eat like a
a cliff bar you know that's vegan but
it's dead it can sit there for like
three years like it's just not vibrating
i know my brother can actually i mean my
wife was talking and we were saying
let's look at one how long could
sometimes i don't i'll be fasting for
i'm not i haven't eaten nothing and
somebody go to the bathroom i take a
[ __ ] this long i said now where so i go
like this to my wife that's it
i go to my wife i said baby i haven't
eaten in 25 days where did this come
from how long does it stay in your
system how could all that stay in your
system without you eating that's crazy
[Music]